ABOUT FIRST, DIVIDIN’ BIDEN.
EXACTLY THREE WEEKS AGO TODAY AS
MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES WERE
CONSUMED BY RIOTING AND LOOTING,
JOE BIDEN DELIVERED THIS
MESSAGE.
>> THE COUNTRY IS CRYING OUT FOR
LEADERSHIP.
LEADERSHIP THAT CAN UNITE US,
LEADERSHIP THAT BRINGS US
TOGETHER.
WE STAND TOGETHER, WE WILL RISE
STRONGER THAN WE WERE BEFORE.
WE WILL MOVE THAT CLOSER TO
JUSTICE.
>> Laura: NO ONE WHO HAS
STUDIED POLITICS THAN LONGER
THAN ABOUT 5 MINUTES REALLY
BELIEVES THIS.
BIDEN HAS BEEN IN OFFICE FOR 40
PLUS YEARS.
SO WHAT IS HE EVEN SPENDING HIS
TIME DOING?
I COULD’VE SWORN BUDDY OF HIS
PROMISE TO DO ALL OF THIS, WHAT
>> I AM ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THAT
GENERATIONS FROM NOW, WE WILL BE
ABLE TO LOOK BACK AND TELL OUR
CHILDREN THAT THIS WAS THE
MOMENT WHEN WE BEGAN TO PROVIDE
CARE FOR THE SICK AND JOBS FOR
THE JOBLESS, THIS WAS THE MOMENT
WHEN THE RISE OF THE OCEANS
BEGAN TO SLOW AND OUR PLANET
BEGAN TO HEAL.
>> Laura: THE PLANET WAS
STARTING TO HEAL, WHAT THE HECK
HAPPENED?
I GUESS JOE IS KIND OF ADMITTING
THAT NONE OF THAT WORKED OUT AND
I CAN SAY TONIGHT, IF OBAMA WAS
HIS STAR POWER AND POLITICAL
SKILLS COULDN’T DO ANY OF THAT,
LORD KNOWS JOE CAN’T.
HE COULDN’T LEAD A RETIREMENT
HOME SING-ALONG LET ALONE THE
LARGEST MILITARY SUPERPOWER ON
EARTH.
A UNIFYING FORCE HE IS NOT.
JUST IN THE PAST THREE WEEKS
WHEN BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN HAS
TACITLY THROWN IN, THEY ARE
TAKING RADICAL, VIOLENT ACTION
TO DO WHAT OBAMA PLEDGED HE
WOULD DO THROUGH POLICYMAKING IN
2008.
REMAKE AMERICA.
IN THIS CASE, SINCE IT REQUIRES
DISRUPTING ELECTIONS, THEY WILL
DO IT.
IF IT REQUIRES INTIMIDATING
BUSINESSES AND INDIVIDUALS TO
PLEDGE THEIR MONEY AND LOYALTY
TO THE TWISTED MISSION, THEY’LL
DO IT.
IF IT REQUIRES ALLOWING
ANARCHISTS TO BURN BUILDINGS,
DESECRATE CHURCHES, DESTROY ART,
LITERATURE, MOVIES, MONUMENTS,
RENAMED TOWNS AND CITIES AND
EVEN THE COUNTRY ITSELF, THEY’LL
DO IT.
AS THIS MAYHEM HAS BEEN CARRIED
OUT COAST-TO-COAST, WE’VE HEARD
NARY A PEEP FROM JOE BIDEN, WHO
IS OBVIOUSLY INCAPABLE OF TRULY
CAMPAIGNING IN THE TRADITIONAL
SENSE.
STATUES OF PRESIDENTS REVERED
EVEN BY OBAMA HIMSELF ARE BEING
PULLED DOWN.
THIS IS ALL SHEER INSANITY, I
KNOW YOU WAKE UP IN THE MORNING,
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS I’M LIVING
IN?
SOME DYSTOPIAN MOVIE YOU’RE
WATCHING OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND THAT’S THE WAY MOST NORMAL
AMERICANS FEEL.
BUT IT’S ALL NECESSARY, THE
CHAOS AND MAYHEM, IF YOUR GOAL
IS TO START THE NATION OVER,
BEGIN IT ALL AT DAY ZERO, THEY
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO ANNIHILATE
THE OLD TRADITIONS TO PRIME THE
POPULATION FOR A NEW NORMAL.
BIDEN TO THE EXTENT HE EVEN
UNDERSTANDS WHAT’S GOING ON AT
ALL SEEMS TOTALLY FINE WITH IT
AND TO CO-OPT ONE OF THEIR MOST
TEDIOUS MANTRAS, HIS SILENCE IS
VIOLENCE.
VIOLENCE AGAINST THE POLITICAL,
HISTORICAL, AND CULTURAL
LANDMARKS OF OUR NATION.
JOE SAYS NOTHING WHEN DAY AFTER
DAY THESE ARE PICKING OVER CITY
BLOCKS, TERRORIZING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, ASSAULTING
INNOCENT AMERICANS BECAUSE THEY
CAN, HE SAYS HE SUPPORTS THE
GOOD POLICE OFFICERS OUT THERE
BUT HE IS MUTUAL AND VIDEOS FLY
AROUND SOCIAL MEDIA LIKE THESE.
>> EVERY [BLEEP] DAY.
EVERY [BLEEP] DAY.
>> YOU ARE WHITE AND YOU’RE
TALKING TO THE TWO BLACK POLICE
OFFICERS.
DO YOU SEE THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
A LITTLE BIT?
>> THEY ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
JUST BECAUSE THEY’RE BLACK
DOESN’T MEAN THEY ARE A PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
>> Laura: DOESN’T SHE SOUND
LIKE A LOT OF FUN ON A SATURDAY
NIGHT?
DO YOU KNOW I BIDEN DOESN’T
SPEAK OUT AGAINST ANY OF THIS?
BECAUSE HE CAN’T AFFORD IT TO
OFFEND THESE HEMP WEARING
NASTIES.
THEY HAVE ENERGY, THEY ARE WELL
ORGANIZED AND WELL-FUNDED AND
THEY DO WHAT BIDEN HIMSELF WILL
NOT DO, FLY OVER AMERICA AND TRY
TO BAIT DONALD TRUMP INTO
ACTION.
THEY WILL ALL VOTE FOR BIDEN, OF
COURSE THEY WILL.
BIDEN IS JUST FIND FINE WITH
THAT, HE NEEDS THAT.
ONE OF HIS ONLY ATTEMPTS TO
CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE AND
DESTRUCTION WAS WAY BACK ON MAY
MAY 31ST.
HE SAID WE ARE NATION IN PAIN
BUT WE MUST NOT ALLOW THIS PAIN
TO DESTROY US, WE ARE A NATION
EXHAUSTED BUT WE WILL NOT ALLOW
OUR EXHAUSTION TO DEFEAT US.
WEEKS, TEPID, CORN POP WOULD
HAVE DONE A MORE CONVINCING JOB
THAN THAT.
THE NATIONAL POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IS ABANDONING BIDEN
WHICH IS ESPECIALLY STUNNING
SINCE ITS MEMBERS ONLY A BACKED
OBAMA BECAUSE BIDEN WAS ON THE
TICKET.
NOW HIS SILENCE, IT JUST
EMBOLDENS PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
>> SPIT IN HIS FOOD, PUT A
TAMPON IN HIS FAT PACINO.
IF THESE PEOPLE EVER COME TO
YOUR PLACE OF WORK, MAKE SURE
YOU TREAT THEM LIKE [BLEEP].
>> Laura: THE MAIN POINT THAT
EVERYONE WATCHING THIS TONIGHT
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND REALLY
CLEARLY, BIDEN EQUALS CHAOS.
HIS CAMPAIGN TEAM THANKS HE CAN
RIDE THIS VIOLENT ANARCHY INTO
POWER IN THE WHITE HOUSE AGAIN
BUT FAR FROM BEING A UNITING
FORCE, A BIDEN PRESIDENCY WOULD
USHER IN TIME OF DIVISION AND
DISTRESSED UNLIKE ANYTHING WE’VE
EXPERIENCED IN OUR LIFETIME.
EVEN WORSE THAN WHAT’S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE HIS ELECTION WILL NOT
LEAD TO MORE CALM BUT IT’S GOING
TO LEAD TO UNREST NOT JUST IN
OUR BELEAGUERED CITIES BUT
EVERYWHERE AND IT’S GOING TO
FOLLOW YOU INTO YOUR PLACE OF
WORK, INTO YOUR PLACE OF
WORSHIP, INTO YOUR KIDS SCHOOLS.
HIS ENTIRE APPEAL TO MODERATE
VOTERS IS HE’S THIS NICE OLD
MAN, WE’LL HAVE A CALMING EFFECT
DURING THESE TURBULENT TIMES BUT
ELECTING HIM WILL NOT SATISFY
THE VIOLENT RADICALS, IT WILL
ONLY EMBOLDEN THEM.
AND THEIR AIM WAS TO UNDERMINE
THEIR FAITH IN ESSENTIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND OUR FOUNDING
PRINCIPLES.
WILL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE REALLY
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN?
I HIGHLY, HIGHLY DOUBT IT.
THIS WILL REQUIRE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPEAK
CONFIDENTLY ABOUT HIS PLANS FOR
THE FUTURE.
HOW THINGS ARE ALREADY GETTING
BETTER, HOW BIDEN WILL MAKE
THINGS WORSE AND MORE TOXIC AND
HOW WE ARE STILL ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.